[موسيقى]
تتسبب صواعق كل عام في نحو اربعه الاف
وفاه وخسائر بمليارات الدولارات الصاعقه
او الورق عباره عن تفريغ للطاقه
الكهربائيه الساكنه المتراكمه بين غيوم
العواصف او بين السحب والارض اقتصر تقدم
العلمي في ما يخص الحمايه من الصواعق على
توجيهها من خلال بنايه عمده في نقاط
مرتفعه تمتص الصواعق الى الارض
استخدمت تجربه الحديثه الليزر مانعا
للصواعق اذ ينتج شعاع الليزر بلازما وهواء
مشهونا بالايونات والالكترونات يصبح بعد
ذلك موصلا جزئيا للهواء ومن ثم يصبح مسار
تفضيليه للبرق اي ان النظر القويه الموجه
نحو السماء يمكن ان يحدث مسار افتراديا
متحركا يمكنه ان يحول مسار ضرب سوعاق
ويوجهها الى قضبان معدنيه ارضيه
استزمت هذه التجربه بناء ليزر قويه يستخدم
التلسكوب لتركيز شعاع الليزر للحصول على
اقوى كثافه عند ارتفاع 100 و 150 متر
اختبر الفريق هذه الفكره على قمه جبل
سانتوس في شمال شرقي سويسرا حيث نصبه لزرا
عالي الطاقه بحجم سياره كبيره يطلق ما يصل
الى الف نبضه في الثانيه قرب برج اتصالات
يضربه البرق 100 مره في السنه على ماذا
اكثر من ست ساعات من التشغيل اثناء نشاط
العواصف الرعديه لاحظ العلماء ان الليزر
حول مسار اربع شحنات برق صاعده
[موسيقى]